if you have a fear of rejection in your
business I'm going to share with you an
inspiring clip from John Paul DeJoria
that I think will help you you're going
to run across a lot of rejection I say
this time in and time out be prepared
for the rejection no matter how bad it
is don't let it overcome you or
influence you keep on going towards what
you want to do no matter what no matter
whether your bills are paid not paid
someone says no a thousand times again
go back to be as enthusiastic on door
number 100 as you were on door number
one but believe in yourself and it's
really all about knowing you have a
great service or a great product that'll
put you in the reorder business so
you're never selling you're trying to
get it in someone's hands whether it's a
service or a product knowing it's so
darn good that they're gonna want to
order it again or tell a friend about it
order and that's the real secret there
so my quick take on this is you're gonna
get rejection and anything that you do
right any new thing that you're trying
to do you're gonna get a lot of
rejection it if you try to learn how to
snowboard you're gonna fall down right
that's your rejection if you try to
learn piano you're gonna make mistakes
you're not gonna sit there and just
instantly become Mozart you're gonna
make mistakes and get rejection over and
over and over again and it's no
different in business when you first
start your company you're gonna make a
lot of mistakes right you're gonna have
the wrong product the wrong service the
wrong price in the wrong target audience
the wrong sales pitch the wrong media
pitch you're gonna make mistakes
everywhere and that's going to lead to
rejection and the key the key is using
that rejection as fuel to learn from and
improve improve your processes improve
your product improve your systems
improve your marketing improve your
pitch improve everything right that
rejection don't use it as a jailer don't
use it as something that you say I'm
never gonna make it because I'm gonna
I've made all these mistakes and nobody
wants it take the feedback and make a
change to how you operate you have to
understand that rejection is normal
rejection isn't failure going out and
being rejected by a client who doesn't
like your idea that's gonna be normal at
the start it's okay everybody goes
through it don't know
take that personally and put it on
yourself and feel like because somebody
said no to me that I am personally a
failure myself use every rejection that
you get to improve yourself and your
product and your business and eventually
you will achieve success thank you guys
so much for watching my question of the
day for you is I want to know how you've
used rejection to move yourself and your
business forward leaving the comments
below I'm curious myself to learn about
your story and I think it could be
inspiring for the other people watching
this video as well so leave a comment
below and tell me your story of
rejection and if you like this video and
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another inspirational entrepreneurship
shot to the arm the kick-start your day